citizens of reject Nation I am here to
bring you a video I don't think I've
seen before I want to break down the
most accurate comic book movies which
implies both reading the comics and
watching the movie now some of these I
haven't seen in a while but from memory
these are I think the 10 most accurate
comic book movies please do like
subscribe hit that Bell if you want to
see more videos like this I'm trying to
convince Greg to let me do a best of
comic book movies video and we're
between 10 25 and 100. I'm trying to let
them do 100 it's not gonna let me do 100
but we're trying to convince him to go
up to 50. so check that video out leave
a comment telling Greg you want to see a
top 50 comic book movie video and pump
me down on Tick Tock where I do 30
second 15 second one minute three minute
short form videos breaking news and
breaking down all sorts of comic
goodness let's get into the most
accurate comic book films
foreign
number 10 a very accurate representation
of the character and a very accurate
representation of the stories around the
storyline but not a direct adaptation of
one comic through line making this kind
of a tricky thing but I've got Batman
Begins Batman Begins is a very good
after adaptation of year one it's a very
good adaptation of young Bruce Wayne
which has been told in so many different
storylines and it's a very accurate
Bruce Wayne but in the comic books there
isn't a Razzle ghoul switch there isn't
uh there's more ducares there's more
certain things but to me this
established Gotham this established the
loss of his family this established all
that year one this established the tone
the closest to most of the Batman
mythology that I'd ever seen and I
consider this one of the most accurate
comic adaptations because it gets who
Bruce and Batman are very early and very
quickly this is 300 uh number nine is
300. that movie changed a lot of things
and doesn't get enough credit Zack
Snyder made a movie that was almost a
storyboard use of the comic book like
that is a frame for frame Recreation he
really played with the palette he played
with the edit he played with the sound
design he did a lot of things to put you
in the world of 300 Frank Miller who
wrote and Illustrated 300 was also very
Hands-On they collaborated and it shows
Frank Miller and Zack Snyder I think are
the duo that goes like Hey we're gonna
do this thing that's gonna be adapting
but also translating but it's gonna work
and I don't think a lot of other Duos
have really done that and I will say I
think Zack Snyder when you want
something translated by way of putting
it into another medium he's the guy
because he's three of these on this list
next up at number eight we have dread
the newest iteration of dread yes the
Stallone one's a fun time but the newest
dread is the comic book Carl Irvin looks
like he was ripped right out of that
page I loved that with Olivia Thirlby as
like the new recruit I love that it felt
like we were living in the comic
sometimes feels like a video game and
the movie felt more like a video game
adaptation than a lot of video game
adaptations because that's what the
comic felt like a lot of the time I love
the use of slow-mo I love the editing
thing that made it feel like you were
going into a comic book frame I love the
pacing that made it feel like certain
action set pieces were Pages flipping
this all very very clearly becomes the
comic book flavor you want out of
something that's so pulp no worry like
Dread and Carl Urban absolutely nailed
it love this movie my number is 2004's
Hellboy now this movie kind of proved
that this is the way to do it when
2019's Hellboy was a direct translation
what's important in making comic book
movies is making sure it's a comic book
movie which needs to be both an
adaptation and a translation which is
why for example Civil War is not much
like the comic book but it works in the
medium of film Hellboy the original
showed what you need to gather the tone
to get the world to make the bprd work
to get all the the underground paranoia
the world of Monsters the Guillermo del
Toro of it all versus trying to make a
frame by frame comparison which is what
they did in the 2019 Hellboy ironically
what works for Zack Snyder and Frank
Miller team up or Zack Snyder working
off you know Alan Moore's work is he
makes the medium of film through the
comic book Lens whereas I feel like when
you're trying to translate too directly
it's trying to film a frame of comic
book and there's a big difference
Hellboy the original is a pitch perfect
example of how you capture a world how
you grow out a world and you make it fit
in your medium using your skill set if
you cast correctly and you have the most
incredible team of special effects
artists assembled love o Force Hellboy
number six remember remember the fifth
of November I think V for Vendetta the
graphic novel is one of the most
important and I think the movie is also
one of the movies that established that
comic book movies aren't just for kids
and I think that's a really important
distinction the adult maturity
intellectualism and and progress that V
for Vendetta made cannot be shortchanged
like the wachowskis produced this film
and they used a lot of their incredible
sensibilities to make this a giant
spectacle and the trailers very much
leaned into the Hugo weaving of it all
and the incredible knife play and
Natalie Portman but if you look at the
actual movie it's talking about very
real very adult things it's talking
about overthrowing a government it's
talking about fascism it's talk betting
and dictator state so it's able to do
what comic books do well which is be
action-packed have interesting
characters and yes [ __ ] Bros on the
internet be political comic books are
inherently political V for Vendetta does
an incredible job being political being
intelligent showing its perspective but
also being action-packed enough and in
this case following the comic enough
that is one one of the most direct
incredible adaptations one of the most
accurate adaptations of any book to
screen number five we are back to the
world of Zack Snyder and this one is
tricky and this one is probably gonna
get me some comic book Kickback because
this one is very accurate for 95 of the
time that last five percent is a huge
change that is Watchmen Watchmen change
the ending of the most important graphic
novel of all time but it did to make it
work for the medium and I would not
change that I love that the show that
just came out on HBO Max that's long
form went back to the original ending
and was able to because it's adapting
the book it's not adapting this movie
it's adapting where the book left off
but since it had long form it was able
to explain the squids it was able to
live in that world what I love about
what Zack Snyder did with Watchman is I
felt like I was living the comic book
and then I got to be surprised but it
still had the emotional resonance it
still had the impact it still had the
ending it still did what the book did
but it adapted it it evolved it for the
medium I'm not saying of all isn't
better I'm saying it it turned it into
the medium of filmmaking now it was
perfectly cast the special effects still
hold up and it looks incredible they use
the comic books basically as a framework
it grabbed frames and somehow translated
them to scream and it did a really cool
thing with sound design and music like
Smashing Pumpkins songs to this day
makes me think of Watchmen because it
was so that world and it was so paranoid
and it was so about what happens when
the world goes wrong and it makes me
feel like who watches the Watchmen it
makes me feel like that sense of dread
and I think this movie is incredible and
I think the ending change Works which is
why it makes my most accurate
adaptations list because it is accurate
to the comics in how it changed number
four is a weird tie because I don't know
how to count we got two movies one of
them is getting this love because it is
an incredible adaptation of the energy
of the comic and also uses the frame so
that is one way I see adaptation work
and that is Scott Pilgrim versus the
world Scott Pilgrim versus the world
feels exactly like the comic the other
one tied at number four is a very
different movie out together but just as
colorful and that is Spider-Man into the
spider-verse the reason I'm picking
Spider-Man into the spider-verse is it
adapts the characters so incredibly well
while not following the comic book
storyline it is accurate to Peter Parker
is it is accurate who spidergwen is it
is accurate to Miles Morales is it
brings us Miles Morales and it does so
while explaining quantum theory and
giving us 10 other Spider-Man while
never sacrificing who miles is while
giving us a miles origin story so what's
interesting to me about into the
spider-verse is it's incredibly accurate
to miles but it's not the spider verse
Story in the comics there's no more Lin
there's no uh Spider totems all that
might come into play and across the
spider-verse but I doubt it all of those
things are so accurate to the comic
books and it is the most accurate for me
of the animated films because it
literally feels like you're turning the
page of a comic book The Animation style
all of those elements make these both
some of the most accurate visual
translations of a comic book I've ever
seen and they're both very special for
changing the game the cacophony of Edgar
Scott Pilgrim cannot be like denied like
what it did to change editing and all
those things and the visual aesthetic
and editing and stylistic choices across
the spider into the spider-verse are
going to resonate through animation for
the rest of time and it feels just like
a comic so these two tied at number four
I'm making the list I can make my own
when this movie came out it was
everywhere and does not get the love it
used to and it should and I think that's
because the sequel kick ass one is the
comic book with big daddy Nick Cage you
change what the comic book was because
now you hear Nick Cage when you read it
because they were so accurate to what
that book was it played with the Beats
it played with the friendship it found
sets that looked just like John meter Jr
drawings it went frame by frame but what
it did was it let the edit of the movie
not make it feel like it was too
beholden to the comic book so it's
accurate to the comic book and it uses
the elements it uses the pacing but it's
not trapped in any sort of way this is
Johnny Jr is one of my favorite artists
of all time this is the closest we will
ever see to the very iconic genre meter
Junior Splash Pages his framing his
choices I think the casting is second to
none when you look back at Chloe Grace
Moretz as hit girl that was all anyone
was talking about that entire summer
when you look at what we first got the
introduction of Adrian Taylor Johnson as
Kick-Ass and that's not to mention again
the Batman Adam West take that Nicholas
Cage did as Big Daddy I think it
elevated the comic book the comic was
already exceptional the movie made it
even better because of how accurate it
was to the comic book that when you read
the comic back it changes your whole
experience and I think this movie uh
doesn't get enough love in the modern
conversation alright this one is very
interesting in assessing it because this
one does not follow any direct comic
book storyline but it changed the comic
books because of how accurate it was to
the character I don't know that there's
ever or at least not since Iron Man
Downey Jr had there been a comic book
character change in the comic books
because of the actor and that is Ryan
reynolds's Deadpool for years they kept
writing Ryan Reynolds into Deadpool
jokes because they were trying to get
this movie made there's a Joe Oak in one
of the early Deadpool comics saying that
the Wade Wilson looks like Ryan Reynolds
crossed with a radioactive Sharpay for
years they were trying to get this going
but then after this movie the character
is written especially the Jerry Duggan
stuff the Brian passane stuff it sounds
like the Ryan Reynolds sensibility
because this is accurate to the comics
because it distilled so much Deadpool
down into one perfect thing this took 30
years of Deadpool comics and it found
his Beating Heart Deadpool is
interesting because he's one of the only
Heroes that wears a mask not to protect
his identity but he's protecting your
stomach from his horrendous face his his
dignity his shame and his use of Comedy
as a defense mechanism were all found in
this one beautiful story where it's a
story about love it's a story about
cancer it's a story about loss but it's
a goddamn superhero story with Quentin
Tarantino action set pieces and lots and
lots of Dick jokes this is a movie that
means you can watch a pegging sequence
on Disney plus right now that is more
accurate that some of the comic books
were about the very same character and
it changed the comic books going forward
Deadpool I think is not just one of the
most accurate comic book adaptations but
it's one of the most important and I
think when you look at R-rated superhero
movies that came out after Deadpool it
owes them a lot of thanks and I'm really
excited and hopeful we'll get to see
something like that with Deadpool in the
MCU I think they will be as accurate as
this first one because of how much Kevin
feige loves the comics and because of
Ryan Reynolds love for this character
but I'm really curious to see what that
looks like in a new world in this shared
MCU so keep it accurate keep it awesome
Deadpool's my number two and my number
one is actually probably gonna be a
little shorter than some of my rest
because it just does all of the things
I've described and it mixes in really
cool medium choices in its flourish of
black and white with color and that is
Sin City it uses the beautiful Noir
style of filmmaking that the comic books
resonate with and adds the color much
like the comics do but it does it in a
way that it feels like when you're
reading a comic book and you're letting
your imagination go how you're flipping
between panels This captures that
sometimes in frame rate sometimes in an
edit sometimes I an acting choice but
this truly feels like reading a comic
almost as much as into the spider-verse
does this is with live action actors the
closest thing I can describe to people
that have never enjoyed comic books
you're in a world that is so fleshed out
every supporting character matters just
as much as the lead every lead is
exactly who they feel like on the
pulpiness of the page you can smell
these frames and it's all authentically
Frank Miller it's all exactly what the
book feels like it's Ultra violent it's
interesting it's empathetic you care and
still everyone's at an 11. everyone is
larger than life everyone is in the
world of Sin City just as Sin City
changed comic books Sin City changed
movies and it is impossibly accurate
impossibly important and when people
talk about comic book movies sin city
deserves some respect on its name this
really helped things get going if blade
gave us the MCU I think Sin City gave us
a lot of the adult oriented content that
we get now and uh yeah put some respect
on its name since the city's the tits
alright let me know what you think if
you read comics and you think there's an
accurate comic book movie I missed let
me know if you disagree with my uh world
view on something being accurate by
being authentic to the character but
different from the comics let me know
like you know your Deadpools and such
and most of all let me know what you're
enjoying reading a lot of you have been
asking for comic book recommendations
for this video I'm gonna say Deadpool
The Good the Bad and the Ugly if you
want some sweet sweet Ryan Reynolds
earnesty with some Deadpool Dead
Presidents if you want that comedy the
Jerry Duggan type comedy that uh Rhett
Reese and Paul Warnick do so very well I
would also recommend you read at least
volume one of Sin City that's my my
passionate cry out to understand what
that world of Pulp is a lot of people
read comics and they think the younger
side but Pulp Comics especially adult
Comics like Frank Miller have a lot of
beauty to them that doesn't get
discussed enough and then finally for my
last recommendation let's go with you
know what [ __ ] it read me from vendetta
a lot of people give a lot of love to
Watchmen as they should I do think it's
the most important comic book maybe ever
made but I don't feel like V for
Vendetta gets enough love and as we live
in a world that uh these conversations
are discussed more often and as these
important elements of politics are
bandied about day to day I think a great
palatable way to discuss Big Brother
Fascism and treason is V for Vendetta
get into it you lovelies uh that is
gonna do it for this episode please do
like subscribe hit that Bell so you find
out when when the next comic corner is I
don't know where the Bell is Greg told
me it was down here I think and I've
always been pointing up here because I
think of bells as above but hit the bell
and then be back for more koi's comic
Corner let me know in the comments what
else you want to see and tell Greg you
want a hundred greatest comic book
movies that's what you do all right see
you next time
[Music]